oui bienvenue à paroles est ainsi c'est
melissa maulin dupuis cette semaine j'ai
une question de max qui me demande
pourrait t'on et devrait être ramené des
non autochtones de lieux importants
comme montréal ou le fleuve saint
laurent
c'est certain max que je suis pas mal
pour qu'on ramène des noms et des mots
surtout de langue autochtone dans des
milieux où ils ont habité le
présentement on parle aussi des fois des
processus de d'enlever des noms qui sont
un peu plus soit controversé on pense à
la rue amherst ah mince avec son
histoire et les premières nations et du
génocide à laquelle ils participé mais
ramener des nombres ramener des noms de
lieux
ça c'est des fois un peu plus difficile
parce que je pense qu'il ya un inconfort
aussi par rapport au fait qu'on connaît
pas les langues autochtones
il ya eu la discussion pour renommer le
pont champlain et pendant ces
discussions le de renommer le pont
champlain mais avec un nom qui vient des
langues cas niang aura c'est sûr des
mots et certaines personnes ont même
nommé le problème mais je serais pas
capable de dire donc c'est certain que
oui ce serait bien que les noms kananga
des noms algonquin pour val-d'or qui
connaît de plus en plus qui apparaissent
mais il faut aussi se débarrasser de
l'inconfort d'avoir à apprendre des mots
qui viennent notre langue et qui est une
honte quand même qui vient du territoire
donc moi je suis pro je pense que ce
serait vraiment un beau geste de
réconciliation qui que les gens puissent
justement apprendre à avoir des nouveaux
noms dans l'or dans leur vocabulaire je
pense pas que ça serait négatif au
québec justement le contraire alors max
merci pour ta question
en espérant que ça n'a répondu et en
espérant vous allez partager une vidéo
et nous envoyer d'autres questions à
espace autochtone